Jennifer Garner is glowing I think  you're really cute Jen Garner all smiles  with an unidentified man the actress is  absolutely beaming in these new photos  she's having a cozy conversation and  laughing with her male friend and the  two even share a hug inside his car and  at Los Angeles Jen looks totally  fresh-faced and gorgeous in the pics  sporting a low-key classic look now a  source tells et this guy might be her  accountant the actress is still legally  married to Ben Affleck but a lot of  money is at stake in their divorce the  two did not have a prenup  the pair is staying friendly spending  time together with their kids but  notably in these new pics Jen is not  wearing a wedding ring and she's been  busy with her career focusing on four  new movie projects as of late so what do  you guys think of Jen's mystery Meetup  we love seeing her this happy give us  your thoughts on twitter using the  hashtag t now